what will be your best advice to those
who are thinking of leaving their
full-time jobs to become a full-time
entrepreneur save your money first don't
just leave unless you know what the hell
you're doing we hear all these stories
about all these people who quit their
job started a company and made all this
money what you don't hear are the
stories of the people who quit their job
started a company and failed miserably
and are now working at a job they hate
before you quit be prepared know what
you're doing save your money have at
least 6 months to live off if you can
and then maybe you're ready to start
your business